[Music]
all right david stay warm up there well
the las vegas convention center will be
the new location for the second round of
doses for the kovid 19 vaccine
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us with the latest on when those
vaccinations will start
sasha they start this tuesday february
2nd but you can start making your
appointment by tomorrow and a reminder
that this is for people who have already
had their first dose
at a health district clinic and are now
eligible to receive their second
the las vegas convention center clinic
will be open tuesday through saturday
in the c1 area of the facility's central
hall
people who are eligible to receive the
second dose of the coven 19 vaccine
at the convention center should have
already received their first dose at
clinics
held at western high school cashman
center or the southern nevada
health district's main public health
center we have two
large pods right now one's doing first
dose one's doing second dose
at las vegas convention center second
dose cashman is first dose
and then we have the capacity here the
health district and all of our partners
with just that capacity it's around
forty fifty thousand
however the second doses of both the
pfizer and moderna vaccine can be
administered
up to six weeks after the first dose
we'll have more information up on our
website
reporting in las vegas madison kimbrough
8 news now